ben shapiro is a short american
conservative
born into a west coast elite family in
1984 he used to be a child prodigy
graduating from high school already at
the age of 16 and graduating from two
universities studying political science
by the age of 23.
benjamin shapiro is 12 years old he'll
be accompanied by his father david
he began training in the violin at age
five in addition to the violin he plays
chess loves baseball completes in track
and field
his goal is to become the first orthodox
rabbi to sit on the supreme court
[Music]
what are the values that's turning its
back
you know i i'm not inclined to continue
an interview with a person as badly
motivated as you as an interviewer so i
think we're done here i appreciate your
time
all right as a university student he
already had his own media consulting
firm
benjamin shapiro legal consulting wrote
multiple national newspaper articles and
had already written two books
but most importantly he tried his hand
at being a hollywood screenwriter
was that a comedy was it sitcom wasn't
drama his mormon dramedy it was based on
harvard law school it's a dramedy
i i've written a couple comedies uh kind
of hour-long dramedies for uh you know
spec script and have they been bought
i know and according to sources ben
shapiro after submitting his script
received a phone call from a tv agent
saying the following one of our agents
googled you and found your website
i'm not sure we can represent you
because he thinks your political views
will make it impossible for you to get a
job in this town
oh wow this sounds rather bad and so
what are some of ben shapiro's political
views that had caused such a reaction
oh here's a good one enemy civilian
casualty is okay by me
i am getting really sick of people who
whine about civilian casualty oh okay
i'm not going to do his voice it's
annoying enough on its own
i'm getting really sick of people who
whine about civilian casualties
maybe i am a hard-hearted guy but when i
see in the newspapers that civilians in
afghanistan or the west bank were killed
by american originated troops
i don't really care in fact i would
rather that the good guys use the air
force to kill the bad
guys even if that means some civilians
get killed along the way
one american soldier is worth far more
than an afghan civilian
the afghans tolerated and supported the
taliban for years no matter what
president bush says
a group doesn't conquer 95 percent of
the country unless it has some support
among the populace
the afghans are fundamentalist muslims
they didn't seem to mind too much that
their women were treated like dogs or
that the taliban enforced sharia muslim
law
so frankly it doesn't matter to me if
some of their civilians quote unquote
get killed for involvement with the
enemy i'm glad the u.s military decided
to use a massive air campaign rather
than going in
full force with ground troops um
holy [ __ ] oh here's another one transfer
is not a dirty word
raise your hand if you are shocked at
the breakdown of the so-called middle
east road map
if you are raising your hand give
yourself a nice hard slap against the
chops
maybe that will wake you up from the
reverie of self-delusion
the road map was doomed from the start
the arab enmity for jews and the state
of israel allows for no peace process
here's the bottom line if you believe
that the jewish state has a right to
exist then you must allow israel to
transfer the palestinians and the
israeli arabs from judea samaria
gaza and israel proper it's an ugly
solution but it's the only solution
and it is far less ugly than the
prospect of a bloody conflict at
infinitum
alright so basically that's ben shapiro
in a nutshell
essentially views arabs as subhuman
advocates for a jewish ethno state
or and also denies the existence of
climate change and basically on every
single social issue he has taken a right
authoritarian side
oh and he also calls himself a
libertarian but as we know that just
means like
right wing fascist he also thought that
barack obama a neo-liberal center-right
president
was basically a communist and was doing
big government
and in general he doesn't really want to
let brown people into the country
enter true allegiance a thriller he
wrote in 2016
which were coincidentally the last
months of the obama presidency
and the time when isis controlled much
of iraq and syria
a blockbuster debut thriller ripped
straight from the headlines
and not only does this book showcase a
shocking lack of writing talent from
shapiro's part he accidentally lets slip
some of his other political views which
are even more disturbing than the ones
we've read in those two articles
so let's get right into it true
allegiance by ben shapiro written in
2016.
it begins with a prologue we're just
going to read this whole chapter
because on one hand it's just two and a
half pages long and on the other
i want you to suffer with me new york
city
by the time jennifer collier hit the
george washington bridge it was already
almost 9 00 am
rush hour the bridge had turned into an
enormous parking lot
jennifer looked at the sea of red lights
before her stretching all the way into
new york
inside there had to be 30 000 cars on
this bridge
all of them moving at two miles an hour
jennifer glanced at her watch
and sighed she was on the west side of
the bridge and she could see its two
enormous steel encased towers looming
before her
in the passenger seat her daughter julie
breathed softly
sleeping jennifer glanced at her watch
again
903 come on she muttered which is when
she heard
it the bridge groaned it was a loud
low groan that made the car vibrate
julie woke up
what was that she asked drowsily the
groan died away
nothing said jennifer probably just a
plane overhead go back to sleep
mommy the bridge groaned again this time
it was longer
more drawn out jennifer felt the brake
pedal vibrate beneath her foot
mommy that's not a plane said julie wide
awake now
the grooming continued booming from
beneath them the bridge was undulating
slightly up and down
jennifer could see the cables of the
suspension bridge oscillating like the
strings of a guitar okay
mommy what's going on julie cried cars
ahead were honking now
urgently pleading for those at the front
of the bridge to hurry up
a few cars were trying to ram their way
through the traffic
wait isn't the bridge like basically
full like how do you ram people if
you're going by two miles per hour or
something
anyway a few cars were trying to run
their way through traffic
pushing other cars towards the end of
the bridge the honking and crashing
combined with the burgeoning low roar
made jennifer's head ache
pound the driving rhythm of her blood
surging through her temples
okay like this sentence is me at the age
of 14
trying to sound like profound and
literary
then the bridge's roar stopped again the
people head of jennifer
kept honking panicking trying to get off
the bridge after about 30 seconds the
honking seemed to die down a little bit
julie's wide eyes grew wider she was
staring at a crash on the other side of
the divider
the flames leaping from the engine of a
smashed toyota
jennifer could see a man's arm hanging
lifeless out of the window
jennifer reached out and gripped julie's
arm it's okay baby she whispered
wetting her lips then time seemed to
stop
the noise of the traffic went silent
jennifer's eyes
opened in horror the bridge before
jennifer tilted sideways
the 604 foot tower before her began to
lean
almost gracefully to her right jennifer
screamed but it was drowned out by the
ear splitting cracking
noise hundreds of thousands of tons of
steel
twisting and bending and grating on each
other
the sound of a million airplanes
crashing at once
jennifer looked to her right as she
heard the steel cable shriek
stretch on the other side of the bridge
she locked eyes with an elderly man
driving a silver lincoln continental
behind him she saw one of the enormous
metal cables snap
clean and slither wildly back and forth
like a
beginning fly fisherman's messy cast
look out she shouted at the man
he couldn't hear her but he turned to
follow her eyes the cable ripped through
the lincoln slicing its occupants in
half
vertically a jet stream of red
flowing in its wake splattering
jennifer's windshield
she opened her mouth to scream and
realized that she was already screaming
so hard no sun was emerging in front of
her
the road itself began to tilt cars that
horizontally toward the railings
bath time playthings of an angry god
the first tower buckled jennifer felt
herself fall as the top level of the
bridge dropped
for a moment she was weightless the
peculiar memory of jumping inside an
elevator when she was a little girl
fleeted through her brain and then the
second level of the bridge
slammed down on top of the first level
at a 25 degree angle
the tower stopped bending but holding
grotesquely
the metal shrieking and moaning smoke
emerging from below
jennifer could hear the screams and
cries of the wounded below her
i mean jesus sounds like a countryside
metal band's first album
an awful crematory smell burned her nose
as scars
exploded beneath her one by one
what are they all teslas muffled by the
tons of cement and steel
sounding for all the world like popcorn
julie was screaming uncontrollably
in the distance sirens sounded eerily
and over the river she could see
emergency helicopters approaching
jennifer fumbled for her purse and dug
through it for her cell phone
she threw side her wallet her makeup
poured out the content on the floor of
the passenger seat
grabbed her cell phone speed dialed bill
it rang once then twice finally it went
to message
i love you she whispered into the phone
yeah
she whispered as her daughter was
screaming uncontrollably next to her
as she did julie pointed through the
front windshield her lips quivering in
silent horror
the second tower was tilting too like
some sort of
horrible snake the bridge responded to
the tower
it tilted and keeled over the road
peeling away before jennifer get left up
to the side universal thousands of cards
turn on their sides
rotate like clothes in a washing machine
jennifer heard the
awful roar i guess the 20th at this
point the unnatural screaming of
thousands of voices
as the stream of red lights before her
begin to disappear
there was nowhere for her to go she
turned to julie
her eyes round with terror she grabbed
her hand it's going to be all right she
whispered
julie nodded slowly jennifer clasped her
by the face and looked into her eyes
i promise you she said it's going to be
all right
now just close your eyes darling julie
closed her eyes
jennifer didn't she looked into the
river below her saw the disappearing
taillights of the thousands of cars
descending into the depths of the hudson
god she whispered oh god
okay so what have we just read so first
off just from a technical writing
perspective
this is dog [ __ ] like if this was
submitted to a literary agent this would
have been rejected after the first
paragraph
just like the tone is all over the place
it's inconsistent the metaphors are
weird as hell
the prose is dog [ __ ] in general and
moreover ben shapiro made like the
number one amateur mistake that aspiring
writers make
you know many beginners start with this
big action scene
you know people getting blown up heads
getting chopped off cars getting
exploded
and the audience gets bored out of their
minds because while the scenes
themselves could be very interesting
we don't have any emotional connections
to the characters we don't know who
jennifer is we don't know who julie is
you know as far as we're concerned
they're just two cardboard cutouts
dry and two-dimensional and only there
to just artificially inject some drama
into the otherwise boring story
and while it is possible to make us care
about characters within one chapter
a you have to be a really good writer
which ben shapiro most definitely isn't
and b the chapter should be longer than
two and a half pages
and by the way ben shapiro's style of
writing just reeks of
someone who's familiar with television
to some extent you know he tried to do
this
big flashy cgi action scene opener on
the pages of a
book where it just doesn't work yeah
child prodigy by the way
but let's take a look at the story now
because that's where the real problems
begin
so this 180 page book has not one not
two not three not four not five but six
viewpoint characters so we have brett
hawthorne the youngest general in the us
army and also a six foot two bear of a
man
he loves america and wants to bomb
terrorists we have mark prescott the
elitist
out of touch probably government
president who doesn't want to protect
the border and hates common people
we have soledad a woman who worked
really hard and pulled herself up by her
own bootstraps but then the government
came and ruined her ranch with
regulations and taxes
and the epa cut her water supply for
like environmental protection reasons
we have levon an african american from
detroit who's this local drug lord runs
a gang
and also operates a protection record
demanding money from businesses
we have ellen who's brett's wife she
exists
with this kid called muhammad who also
exists i guess
and oh wait we actually have another
viewpoint character o'sullivan
a police officer who shoots a black kid
so yeah this is our star-studded cast of
characters i guess
and an interesting and rather revealing
pattern i've noticed is that pretty much
all the major characters have some kind
of atrocity committed to them
by a black person either directly or
indirectly
of course except for levon because he
himself is the one who commits the
atrocities
because you know he's black so what else
would he do in a bishop hero book
anyway the story begins with brett
hawthorne and then we get one whole page
of happenings
until ben shapiro decides it's time to
go back to a long
[ __ ] flashback recapping brett
hawthorne's entire [ __ ] life
all the way to that first page and this
is another theme about this book
that ben shapiro is kind of weird about
people being big and tall
like he himself is a manlet but like
this book is just full of these gigantic
rippling muscley dudes and it's so
awkward to read over and over again like
every single person is like the [ __ ]
hulk reborn
the men at least like here for example
on this very first page
hawthorne was a bear of a man 6-3 in his
bare feet
and 215 pounds in his underwear
and also correct me if i'm wrong but i
don't think there's such a thing
as a city's poor part of town like it's
either one or the other right
like there are expressions such as the
city's poor parts or
poor part of town but i don't think
these two things can be used together
and honestly as someone who had already
written two books by the age of 21
i would expect ben shapiro to know these
things anyway so the chapter goes on and
ben shapiro gives us
one page of plot followed by 15 pages of
flashbacks
and then after the flashbacks we finally
get back to the main plot for
four entire lines and then the chapter
ends
but what ben shapiro writes in these
flashbacks is already i would say
somewhat concerning so the flashbacks
begin at brett hawthorne's
high school years where ben feels the
need to specifically point out that the
school he went to was heavily black
but just just listen to this okay he'd
been a shy kid
gentle quiet but like a reed but he
learned one skill pretty quickly at
thomas edison
high how to talk his way out of a bad
situation
that he learned from derek on the second
day of school
brett was sitting by himself at lunch he
wasn't one of the irish kids and he
wasn't one of the italian kids so he
couldn't sit with those cliques
and he had made the mistake the day
before of trying to befriend a couple of
the black kids
that hadn't gone well he had ended up
with a black eye
and a few new vocabulary words to add to
his dictionary
yeah so in this book black people are
essentially these like
wild out of control animals but wait
there's more
the chapter goes on so today he sat
alone
until he made the mistake of looking up
standing above him glaring at him was a
behemoth
a black kid named yard nobody knew his
real name
everybody just called him yard because
he played on the school football team
stood six foot five clocked in at a
solid 280 pounds
and looked like he was headed straight
for a lifetime of prison workouts
okay so in writing there are two kinds
of third person narration
third person limited and third person
omniscient third person limited
means that you view the events from the
character's viewpoint
that means presenting the world through
the character's eyes filtered through
their personality and previous
experiences
now ben shapiro on the other hand uses
third person omniscient
meaning that the information is
presented to us through an omniscient
narrator who usually knows more than the
character
now because of this and because ben
shapiro has very little writing talent
in this case the omniscient narrator is
ben shapiro himself
so whenever you read [ __ ] like this you
know making a mistake by trying to
befriend some black people
headed for a lifetime of prison workouts
you're not listening to this neutral
aloof narrator
you're listening to ben shapiro himself
and so let's also talk about the
importance of promises and payoffs in
stories
it's very important to make the right
promises to your readers and then make
good on those promises
this whole ill-fated high school section
is dedicated to showing us how brett
learned how to talk his way out of a bad
situation
and he learned that from this kid called
derek but the thing is derek didn't talk
his way out of the situation he just
started singing and acting weird
and then this caused the big black
animal to get confused and back off
and then it just never comes up again
brett is never put in a situation where
he has to talk his way out and so he can
utilize the skill he's learned
but then again shapiro couldn't even
keep his own narrative straight for a
few paragraphs
so you know i don't know what i expected
and so as the chapter goes on we get
into another
minor aspect of ben shapiro's writing
namely that he's super weird about women
you know he himself doesn't have much
experience with women he himself being a
virgin all the way until he was married
oh and by the way he also thinks that
women should not have the right to have
an abortion
not even in cases of rape or incest by
the way only if the mother's life is in
jeopardy he also thinks that doctors who
perform abortions should be
jailed yeah he's a libertarian by the
way okay so this is how ben shapiro
handles writing women and flirtation no
loitering cadet
the voice was musical for some reason
the image of a woodwind came to mind
a southern woodwind since her accent
sang of long
summers and lemonade what brett didn't
care about that
he turned irked and found himself face
to face with a beautiful young woman
about 17 staring aggressively at him
no she said i expected better from a
cadet
hanging around here driving away all the
customers and what if i do drive them
all away
what if i was the last man left on earth
standing right here at this shop
he couldn't believe his mouth was moving
this well
okay the thing is it's not like i've
read this line over and over again
i just don't get it like what if i do
drive them away what if i was the last
man left on earth
standing right here at this shop like
what about this is like
good or i don't know like what does it
even mean is it some kind of pop culture
reference
or like is this how ben shapiro actually
imagines flirting or something
because i mean this is less cary grand
smooth talking and more
conservative filthy frank in search of a
mate so
what if i was the last man standing
around here huh i'm a virgin by the way
he couldn't believe his mouth was moving
this well considering his stunk had
turned to glue against his molars
would you do me the honor of letting me
take you for a walk along the pier
he flashed what he hoped was his most
charming smile i've been asked by cadets
before
and i'll be asked by cadets again she
shot back without hesitation
and if you'll wipe that green that looks
like you're eating tax and manure off
your face
a grin that looks like you're eating tax
and manure why would you grin if you
ever whatever and if you buy one of
these here pictures
i'll think about it the smile
disappeared his hand flashed to his
wallet
he took out a 20 bill fingered it then
handed it
over pointing at a watercolor of a
palmetto line road along the shore i'll
take that one
she handed it over wait who handed it
over to whom
did ben misstype it and did he mean like
he handed it over to her or like
who's she and who did he like she handed
it over
so how about it she raised an eyebrow in
mockery
no i'll think i'll pass he felt the
frustration rise in his chest
but i just bought the picture i'm not
that cheap a date she laughed
this time the musicality of it pierced
him
alright so ellen brad's future wife is
presented to us as this like
unbearable caddy [ __ ] which really goes
to show you how much ben shapiro really
knows about women or dating in general
and just listen to this so maybe his way
with words didn't win alan
but his persistence did by the time he
bought his fifth picture
she agreed to a walk by the 10th they
were going steady
two years later they were married and so
okay first off not only is ellen this
catty [ __ ]
she's also this art connoisseur gold
digger and
also ben if you don't know anything
about women or dating
then just research it before writing
about it or just
skip it all together because this is
basically dating 101
you know if someone wouldn't even go out
with you unless you buy them a bunch of
[ __ ] then that's a huge red flag
anyway dating lessons over back to the
book further in the flashback ben also
mentions that brett
just learned pashtu for some reason part
2 being a common language in afghanistan
but then ben
says that this was a simple coincidence
and it's like
you was it like who the [ __ ] learns
pashtu just because you know and it's
like ben has complete control over
what's happening in this book why didn't
he write stuff like
oh yeah he was expecting that
afghanistan is going to be a problem or
something so he
got down into the u.s army's pashtu
courses or something i don't know
i mean this is just so [ __ ] lazy
writing it it would have taken him
literally like one sentence to explain
it but instead he literally just goes oh
yeah yeah hey
brett just knows party is just awesome
you know he does it yep it's coincidence
anyway so at some point ben mentions
that ellen had like a miscarriage
but he can't do it without sounding
gringy again
he picked her up in his powerful arms
held her tight so small against him
anyway the flashback continues saying
that some guards flushed down a quran on
the toilet in guantanamo bay
and then the story came out in newsweek
which is a publication that ben doesn't
agree with i guess
and then this causes riots all over the
muslim world
including afghanistan where the
population gets all riled up and the
afghani president tries to appease the
inflamed population
by just listen to this okay the deal for
the military bases was all but dead the
administration was scrambling
the afghan president in an attempt to
appease his inflamed population
demanded that u.s troops change their
rules of engagement
to avoid civilian casualties in the
process
endangering more american soldiers like
ben uh hey do you remember that article
we saw in the beginning
yeah enemy civilian casualties are still
okay by ben it seems
and i find this [ __ ] fascinating like
how [ __ ]
sociopathic do you have to be and just
how [ __ ] lost do you have to be in
general to write something into your own
story like
oh yeah the afghani president as a
symbol of opposing the americans
asked the americans of like hey could
you please like
could you be more careful like you know
when you do an airstrike for on the
taliban or something you always like
swat out three dozen civilians
could you maybe not you write that into
your story and then you look at it it's
like huh
yeah let's see let's say this shows how
how unreasonable these these brown
people are yeah this afghani president
is a traitor
what a sociopathic little [ __ ] back
jesus christ
but wait there's more he'd been ushering
a cnn crew around
gotta keep these schmucks from reporting
that we eat muslims he told alan
but but
just two lines ago you wrote you told us
ben
that the us army in afghanistan uses
engagement methods
that results in mass death of civilians
so much so that the afghani president
had to go out and be like hey could you
please could you please [ __ ] not
so i mean ben shapiro is so [ __ ]
stupid he has so little talent as a
writer
that even in this world of make-believe
in the world that he shapes completely
that he he can write whatever he wants
to he's his book even in that world
his [ __ ] narrative doesn't hold up
the cnn crew
is right the americans are killing
civilians you know how i know because
ben shapiro told me two lines ago
anyway ben shapiro is not good for my
blood pressure
and just look at how he describes the
cnn crew anyway which is a publication
that ben shapiro in real life
doesn't like the members of the cnn crew
were yawning
one of them leaned up against the pool
of his stall camera still fixed to his
eye
girl no he said lazily i think we've got
about enough footage
brad turned to speak and from behind the
camera man he saw a child on a donkey
about 300 feet away yeah okay so all
these cnn crews like uh
whatever man can we just go we're
liberals we're just like not
interested we just we just want to make
the americans look bad
one of the soldiers moved towards the
donkey get away from it
brett barked the child began to cry the
cameraman
zoomed in eagerly this was absolute gold
a crying afghan child
frightened to death by the awful
americans
and it's like this is just childish like
is
we're looking into the mind of ben
shapiro right now he was a 32 year old
man when he wrote this like this is what
he thinks cnn is like
the child prodigy dude anyway so the
donkey has a bomb strapped to it and a
child as well
and then brett takes out his gun and
shoots out the cell phone and a donkey
which was going to detonate the bomb
and it's like dude like how over the top
do you have to be
like this isn't even an action movie
this is this is a [ __ ] jojo battle
yeah dude that's it [ __ ] [ __ ]
brett is a stand user
like [ __ ] stand user brett hawthorne
stand civilian casualty like the [ __ ]
i'm getting distracted but this is the
only way for me to dull the pain
uh anyway but if you thought that this
chapter cannot get any lower if you
thought that things cannot get any
dumber
just check this out there's an
ambassador called
boragaard frederick falcov who ben
describes as this sort of
malicious member of the democratic
establishment who only got the job in
afghanistan because he donated a bunch
of money to the president who's a
democrat
and so ben wants to paint him in a
negative way because of course he's a
democrat you know he's bad
and so this is how he goes about it the
setup is that the kabul u.s embassy
comes under attack and the taliban are
like shooting at it throwing molotov
cocktails at it and their general chaos
and panic all around
when brett turned back to give his man
orders he saw the ambassador in the
corner
cowering under a desk clutching his
briefcase to his chest he was screaming
at brett and his high toned boston
brawling accent
your job is to keep me safe so do your
god damn job
shut the [ __ ] up brett said the coldness
of his stone
stunned the ambassador into silence then
an odd
keening noise emanated from his mouth it
rose higher and higher
louder and louder what like wha
what is that like
like how am i supposed to interpret this
[ __ ] description
so brett punched him in the mouth not
hard just enough to stun him
get your panzers onto the roof right now
he said slowly
glaring now falkov nodded brett motioned
and the marines pouring into the
compound formed a phalanx around the
ambassador
whose eyes had gone blank with fright
and shock the group
moved towards the staircase the
helicopter pad was on the roof
it was already overloaded every staffer
with an ounce of brains had rushed to
the roof after the fence came down
brett flashed back to the old videos of
the last helicopter leaving saigon
with all the wailing civilians
attempting to climb onto the landing
skids
falcov took one look at the crowded
helicopter filled with civilian staffers
then he pointed at one woman she was
crying
off he cried i'm the ambassador
she was crying too wait you just said
that she was crying or whatever
mr ambassador brett said we can get you
out another way
screw that falcop was nearing hysterics
again
that's my helicopter and i'm getting on
it and i'm in charge
the woman got off the helicopter sobbing
from the street the noise rose then fell
silent
her sobs echoed in the quiet along the
pope of the chopper blades like
what yeah right dude her sobs echoed in
the quietness of
brett moved to help the woman when the
bullets struck her in the throat
tearing it open dude we're back to the
jojo battle
she looked up at him blood gurgling onto
the roof
the blood pumped out slowly she tried to
speak
grabbed brett's hand hard then her eyes
went cold
brett hit the deck as bullets began
taking down the people on the roof
one by one move toward the center of the
roof he yelled
they can only spot you from the street
the helicopter rotors went transparent
and the machine began to take off
brad caught falco's eyes if i see you
again you son of a [ __ ] but i thought
i'll make you pay for that but feldkov
didn't see him
he was too busy smiling a trickle of
blood spilling down his split lower lip
and holy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude like
isn't it just [ __ ] amazing like this
is this isn't even hamvista this is
beyond hemphista this is unintentional
parody
yeah and then the evil democrat
ambassador pulled down
a sobbing woman let's say and then he
was smiling and she
scared and like the throat splattered
and
her gargling blood and the ambassador
was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] like oh ben alright so
the talibans then overwhelmed the
embassy and like
brett jumps down the roof with his
troops but before that there's like a
split second moment where he like
reflects kills a taliban with his pistol
you know he barely has enough time to
react but he does have enough time to
think you know democrats bad
alright so he jumps down breaks his arm
and then goes to hide for a few hours
and then we're back to where we started
and then this was a chapter like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
like this is this is offensive like i'm
i'm offended
but alas the damned cannot know peace so
let's head deeper into the book
the next circle of hell president
prescott washington dc
and this chapter will be about ben
shapiro's economic positions
so yeah get ready for some galaxy brain
[ __ ]
right so as i've alluded to before
president prescott in this book is
basically just barack obama
and i think you'll see why so let's
begin we simply can't pay for it sir
white house chief of staff tommy bradley
was standing over the president's desk
in the oval office
a sheaf of budget papers in his hand
crumbled wrinkled papers covered in red
notes
the numbers just didn't add up and
president prescott
didn't care listen to me tommy said the
president
my real action relies on our ability to
secure funding for this action
you know that i know that the polls show
it we don't have a choice in the matter
okay so we're eight lines in and there's
already a lot of problems with this
first off i've never heard about paper
being crumbled with a b
i thought it was written with a p as in
crumpled paper
and once again from a technical writing
perspective what ben shapiro did here
was a huge rookie mistake
you never ever ever have two characters
monologue at each other sharing
information they already know just to
share it with the audience
and this isn't even like 70s 80s kind of
rookie mistake you know when old fantasy
books used to begin with huge info dumps
this is a 19th century mistake commonly
known as
maid and butler dialogue okay this comes
from old stage place
where they would have the maid and the
butler come onto the stage
at the beginning of the play and they
would step up and the butler would say
as you know the master is away
for the weekend taming some wild horses
and he loves horses
and the maid would say yes and as you
know
the mrs is here alone with the
horsemaster
and he would say yes and as you know and
then they would like set up the whole
plot
by having a conversation about things
they already know about
alright so just from a technical
standpoint this chapter is a complete
failure already
like seriously you don't make mistakes
like this and get published
so anyway let's move on to the
ideological content of this chapter
because jesus [ __ ] christ
like i've never seen someone be like
this obviously [ __ ] wrong and yet be
so like all gas no breaks
alright so this not so subtle setup for
this chapter is that the president's
ratings are going down and the economy
is going to [ __ ]
there's high inflation and the
unemployment rate is 25
so this is like great depression level
crisis so prescott did what prescott
knew how to do
he survived the easiest way to survive
and his predecessor's wars
no matter what the cost and then pump up
spending at home
there was no glory to be won on the
poppy fields of afghanistan
everlasting glory didn't come in the
form of military victory in this day and
age
it came from the form of everlasting
social programs that grew and inured to
the benefit of all americans
fdr was worshiped not because of world
war ii but because of social security
lbj had lost vietnam but he had won the
great society
i mean yeah
big men prescott knew required big
governments
and b governments required big spending
okay so
a really [ __ ] subtle ben thank you so
prescott spent
he spent on green technologies on
education programs on food stamps and
highway and medical mandates
he spent on vacations and dinners and
public works projects
every dollar spent he told the american
public created five dollars no
10 in commerce the money could either be
hidden in the mattresses of the rich or
it could be shared with everyone
um yeah his poll numbers went up
initially he waited for the inevitable
economic bump that would enshrine his
legacy and assure his re-election
and nothing happened the economy
sputtered and spluttered along not quite
collapsing but certainly not booming
and oh my god like this is the most
basic [ __ ] [ __ ] i thought even
conservatives agreed to this
the economic multiplying effects of
infrastructure projects is a [ __ ]
fact
it has been proven time and time and
time again that
during crises you spend you ramp up
state spending into useful projects such
as infrastructure because that's what
helps
the country get out of the crisis do you
know which country did it
china they started dumping billions upon
billions into all kinds of projects
and this is the reason why in 2020 the
us has 735 kilometers of high-speed rail
while china has
35 388 kilometers
and hey do you know which country didn't
spend in response to the crisis
the uk in 2010 led by conservative david
cameron
do you know what the result was
recession and i just don't get it why
ben shapiro keeps battling this horse
[ __ ] you know
all this happened four to five years
before this book was written
and oh my god he's so [ __ ] dumb
because he could have included this as
oh yeah the democrat president started
spending but since they were democrats
they were like spending incompetently
and the money went to all the wrong
things and their cronies or whatever and
then the economy didn't recover
like that would have made some sense
within ben shapiro's universe but he's
so
dumb and at the same time so buried in
his own propaganda that he just couldn't
[ __ ] help himself
but hey it actually gets worse check
this out
then a miracle in the middle of the
night prescott woke up with a phrase
ringing in his brain
over and over it was as though a higher
power had placed them in his mind
he grabbed a pen from his bedside drawer
and wrote it down
work freedom the work freedom program
prescott's work freedom program
everyone recognized the value of freedom
but what did that mean other than the
right to a job
freedom meant nothing if you couldn't
put bread in your children's mouths at
night
and america was a country of workers
freedom was work and work was freedom
work freedom simple easy repeatable
genius
i wonder how ben shapiro would feel if
someone compared him to nazis
ah god what a piece of [ __ ] but then
later in the chapter the
evil big goodman president gives a
speech
where he says things that ben shapiro
tries to present as a [ __ ] crazy
person saying them
but just listen our country is too great
our economy too powerful our mission on
this planet too important for us to
continue to tolerate the growing gap
between rich and poor
between those who are lucky and those
who are less fortunate for generations
our parents and grandparents have told
us that
this was the land of opportunity coming
from the soviet union or from nazi
germany
they were right compared to those places
america was a land of opportunity
but that did not mean that american
opportunity was open to all
african-americans were denied work based
on the color of their skin
women were prevented from entering the
workplace based on sexism
minorities of all stripes are subject to
discrimination at the hands of an
unfeeling and uncaring majority we still
live with the vestiges of that system
a system that allowed some to exploit
their privileged status to bully others
and to build their own wealth from the
back of those they could chain to
low-paying jobs
a system that sucked workers dry then
tossed them to the ground in contempt
a system that assumed that some would
prosper while others would succeed
that some people deserved to work while
others did not
there are still those in congress who
advocate for such system who say that if
we reject that system we reject america
the critics and cynics are wrong that
old systems time has passed
we are better than that system we are
stronger than that system
together we can fix the imbalances that
plague our society
we can ensure that everyone in this
country has equality of opportunity by
ensuring that everyone has the right to
work
our corporations must no longer line
their own pockets and pet their bank
accounts at the expense of the workers
they refuse to hire
our companies must no longer tell us
that the free hand of the market will
solve everything or that handing money
over to the rich will allow it to
trickle down to the less fortunate
we have seen the results of that
philosophy firsthand we have seen the
skyrocketing unemployment
the fiscal mismanagement the utter
irresponsibility and its fallout
we have seen what happens when the
market is left to its own devices
we have seen the injustices and wrongs
that ensue
i know that some of my political
opponents would like to call this plan
irresponsible
i know they sling around words like
socialism and marxism and
redistributionism
and they hope to scare you with those
words
um but isn't this what republicans have
been doing for
decades like isn't this exactly what
they're doing even right now isn't this
what ben shapiro is doing right
now hey do you remember when bernie
sanders was running and he was like
um you know maybe you know for-profit
education
for-profit healthcare and millions of
people dying tens of thousands of people
in like medical bankruptcy
you know as the richest country on the
planet maybe we shouldn't you know
and wasn't the conservative reaction to
that kind of like
oh my god bernie is a [ __ ] red he's a
[ __ ] comedy he wants to bring
socialism to america he's he's going to
turn america into vuvuzela
in two weeks and he's going to institute
read history be
generalism also like didn't
conservatives call obamacare communist
or like socialist or whatever
like this is incredible like ben shapiro
set out to write the character of
prescott as this
unsympathetic crazy person but ben is so
lost in his own little ideological echo
chamber
that he accidentally ends up making
prescott one of the most sympathetic
characters
in the book like he tries to fix the
economy using known and proven methods
he's against the war in afghanistan he
wants to stop the us army killing
civilians
he wants to regulate the market he
refuses to invade mexico because of
cartel atrocities
and according to man shapiro these are
all crazy positions to hold
like just how out of touch do you have
to be to have these opinions
how out of touch has the conservative
movement has become over the years it's
legitimately concerning
and speaking of that before we turn on
to the next character soledad i'd like
to say a few words about some worrying
tendencies within the american
conservative movement
yeah trust me this ties into the next
chapter really [ __ ] heavily
and i'm talking about conservatives
tendency to threaten with violence or
outright terror attacks
should things not go that way for
example have you ever heard the phrase
if they come from my guns i'll give them
the bullets it's a rather common form of
essentially gorilla the king among
conservatives
oh and also have you ever heard of this
oregon republican threatens state
troopers over climate change bill
send bachelors and come heavily armed
and with the sand bachelor's part he of
course means that
he doesn't want to create widows when he
kills them and i mean
what other group in america can get away
with openly threatening the government
like imagine if this was said by the
leader of some american like
muslim group or something they would get
[ __ ] drone striked within five
seconds
so yeah among conservatives there is
this bizarre entitlement to make
terrorist threats against their own
state enter soledad ben shapiro's other
attempt at creating a sympathetic
character
she's disliked california central valley
pull up by her own bootstraps rancher
whose ranch was ruined by government
taxes and the environmental protection
agency cut off her water supply to save
some fish
and so she went broke she was forced to
lay off all her employees mexicans
mostly
and then ben specifically tells us that
one of her former employees takes his
family to east los angeles where his son
applies to a high school where one of
his classmates tries to recruit him into
a gang and then when he refuses the
other gang members
beat him to death in the toilet and ben
shapiro doesn't specifically say that
they were black but
when conservatives talk about gang
members i mean we all know what they're
talking about
and so soledad's ranch goes bust it
dries up completely
and so listen to this she woke up with
the television blaring
pictures of the blown outside of the
water resources control board offices on
i street first street in sacramento led
every news network
all of them even soledad was somewhat
shocked by the security video
it looked like something out of a
schwarzenegger movie with cement and
steel blasting into the night sky
plumes of smoke and ash rose from the
bombing side solidad was grateful that
the truck had been completely
eviscerated by the explosion
but she knew that the federal
investigators would check the camera
footage
it was only a matter of time before they
did proper forensic analysis
and traced the truck there were no
casualties
soledad had insisted on a weekend attack
to avoid any human toll
okay so first off you don't know that in
fact big office buildings usually have
at least
some people in them during weekends you
know people doing some additional work
that just came up
lots of maintenance gets done on
weekends so that the employees will not
be bothered
plus there's pretty much always security
present so yeah soledad wanted to take
revenge for her [ __ ]
dried up ranch in the central valley so
rip
dave the security guy [ __ ] laura the
receptionist
you know mike mike mike mike and mike
all plumbers
working on the toilets or some [ __ ] bill
the hvac repair guy who was working on
the roof is now in low earth orbit
okay so according to ben there were no
casualties which apparently makes this
okay
like i'm not kidding throughout the book
ben shapiro insists that solidad is a
positive character
like she's some role model to be
followed or something or some tragic
victim whose hand was forced by the evil
government
which is like oh yeah dude like her
wrench was cut off from from the water
supply so
you know she had no choice she had to
blow up a civilian building that was her
only recourse
and then ben shapiro mentions that the
local farmers basically just organized
this terrorist militia and now they had
a standoff with swat
which pardoned me if i'm wrong but isn't
this exactly what the taliban do
you know a countryside militia facing of
the us government's troops
i mean for [ __ ] sake the book began
with a standoff with the taliban where
the taliban blew a hole into the embassy
but apparently according to ben shapiro
when conservatives do the exact same
thing it's suddenly okay
and so he writes the media went
absolutely berserk
the governor called her a domestic
terrorist put her on par with al qaeda
like once again ben tries to portray
this as some crazy liberals getting
triggered over this or something
but he ends up refuting himself because
what she did is
exactly what al qaeda does that's
exactly how al qaeda thinks
they just are on the wrong side i guess
so when solidar says
because i'm not going to stand for my
government yes it's my government too
violating my god-given rights to water
my land
like if you replace water with rule over
you'll get what the talibans think and
then the taliban will
build a big bomb and put it on a truck
and like drive it into
a civilian building and like explode it
there and that's bad because you know
they're brown and muslim
but when solidar does it hey whatever if
the taliban fighters show up to like
threaten the us
troops then you know that's bad but if
some redneck dumb [ __ ] militia shows up
to [ __ ]
threaten to shoot the swat team hey
that's okay they're just
they're just exercising their god-given
rights according to ben shapiro anyway
because once again he was the one who
wrote all this
but then ben shapiro once again boy
genius by the way
cannot keep his own [ __ ] narrative
straight at the beginning of the chapter
he writes that solidarity's water was
turned off and so this caused the whole
thing to dry up
and her cattle to die of thirst but
towards the end he writes this
soledad expected to be arrested that day
but through the night nobody approached
the house
the drones kept circling the cameras
kept rolling they shut off her phone
lines
and her electricity and her water so her
wrench does have water after all at
least some
so then even if it's not enough to
irrigate the fields how come her cattle
died of thirst i mean
it's established that she isn't exactly
this like kettle magnate or something
like how come she couldn't fill up a
bunch of buckets in the kitchen and like
give the water to the cattle so they
don't die
like seriously ben how could you [ __ ]
this up like the lack of water was the
central conflict within
solidad's arc anyway let's just move on
one last character in this complete
train wreck [ __ ] show
leave on alright so levon is black
and so so far black people in true
allegiance have had the following roles
they beat up high school brett when he
tried to befriend them they beat this
mexican kid to death when he refused to
join their gang
and then one of them yard tried to beat
the [ __ ] out of high school brett for no
reason
and then there was derek who just acted
like a [ __ ] weirdo for like two
seconds
enter levon a drug dealing racketeer
gang leader who extorts money from local
businesses
oh and he's also a race hustler who uses
black lives matter and the death of a
black child
to basically just officially take over
the area he lives in
holy angels on the throne of light like
if i wrote this down
and showed it to someone and then told
them yeah this was written by the kkk
grand wizard or something
they would believe it i would believe it
hell no one would have any reason to
doubt me
and also what's the deal with ben
shapiro and
african-americans i mean just the way he
writes about them
is this some kind of like suppressed
fetish or something
is he into like interracial cocholdri
because so far every black person is
like
ah yeah let's say let's say that the big
black muscular
man just abuses the little pudgy white
boy like it's so awkward to read
oh by the way levon is 6'3 and 220
pounds of shredded
muscle and he orchestrates the death of
this black kid by a police officer
and he plans it all out and executes it
to the point where he gives the kid a
toy gun
he tells the kid where to go when to be
there what to do
and then he disables all the cameras
around the area
except for one which will record the
police officer from behind
so that people will not get a good look
at what's happening and let me just read
this section it's going to be a double
trouble
both from story and from a technical
perspective
levon's smile never faltered it's
shakespeare he said
it means you'll learn to trust me
crawford laughed
loudly this time then he looked at levon
curiously
quoting dead honkeys he twinkled you
might be useful yet
two hours to the end of the shift riccio
sullivan looked down at his watch
and oh my god look at this this is how
ben shapiro thinks viewpoint shifts work
no space no line break no indent no
symbol
and like if you want to be a dramedy
writer in hollywood i mean i guess if
you wanted to be at some point
you might think it's a useful skill to
be able to indicate the end of a scene
alright so we're on oh sullivan now i
guess and he gets dispatched to this gas
station where there's this black kid and
just listen to this he looked through
the glass door saw the wrecks of funions
and doritos the cashier's counter lay
behind a thick pane of double plexiglass
nobody said behind it then he heard the
voice
hey pig it said the voice was in deep it
was the voice of a child
and the kid stood outside the door of
the quick mart leg spread
arms hanging down by his sides a cute
black kid wearing a simpsons t-shirt and
somebody's old converse sneakers and
baggy jeans
you know if a black kid wears clothes
it's obviously someone else's he must
have stolen it or something you know
what these dorkies are like
on his hip stuck in those baggy jeans
was a pistol
it looked like a pistol anyway but
o'sullivan couldn't see clearly
the light wasn't right he could see the
bulge but not the object
o sullivan put his flashlight back in
his belt and put his hand back on his
pistol
the greasy handle still warm to the
touch stop right there pig
the kid said his hand began to creep
down towards his waistband
oh sullivan pulled the gun out of its
holster leveling it at the kid
put your hands above your head do it now
[ __ ] you honky the kid shot back
get the [ __ ] out of my neighborhood then
he left a cute kid's laugh
oh sullivan looked for sympathy behind
those eyes and found none
you know what these dorkies are like
they have no empathy they're like
animals they're gonna beat your child to
death at high school if they don't join
their gang
oh [ __ ] oh sullivan thought then he said
hands up right now
the kid laughed again a musical tinkling
noise
you ain't gonna shoot me pig what are
you afraid of a kid
and hey you know what aside from the
honky and pig and whatever the kid has a
point
like so far this situation is that
there's this kid sitting in front of a
store or something he has something in
his pants which
kinda looks like a gun but the light
isn't right but hey it could be a toy
gun or a [ __ ] best dispenser for all
sullivan knows and this kid makes one
move
like his hand like twitches towards his
pants and oliver reacts by [ __ ]
pointing the gun at him
oh sullivan could feel every breath as
it entered his lungs
no kid i don't want to shoot you he said
but i need you to cooperate
put your hands above your head right now
the kid's hand shifted to his waistband
again
o'sullivan's hands began to shake get
the [ __ ] out of my neighborhood the kid
repeated
oh sullivan looked around stealthily
still nobody on the street
totally empty the sweat on his forehead
felt cold in the night air
in the retraining sessions at the
station they told officers to remember
the nasty racial legacy of the
department
be aware of the community's justified
suspicion of the police
ah so it's the liberal's fault i see
thanks ben
right now all sullivan was thinking
about was getting this kid with the mtis
to back the [ __ ] off
go on home he said oh yeah dude go go
home as i point this [ __ ] gun at you
yeah that's how that works
you go home white boy said the kid his
hand moved lower
and just just listen to this just listen
to how ben shapiro lays the groundwork
to justify a police officer executing a
kid
suddenly o'sullivan's head filled with a
sudden clarity his brain with a
preternatural energy
he recognized the feel of the adrenaline
hitting he wasn't going to get shot on
the corner of iowa and then dike outside
a shitty convenience store in a shitty
town by some eight-year-old
bleed out in the gutter of some city the
world left behind he had alive too
the gun felt alive in his hand the gun
was life
yeah okay so this poor trained
professional police officer had no
choice but to
execute this wild animal because he was
afraid for his life otherwise and
okay whatever [ __ ] you ben the muzzle
was aimed dead at the kid's chest
no way to miss with the kid this close
and oh my [ __ ] god dude like listen
to the [ __ ] you're saying
like it's a [ __ ] police officer going
oh yeah okay it's okay dude i can
totally shoot this kid
like how [ __ ] sick and twisted do you
have to be on the inside to look at this
and it's like oh yeah oh sullivan is the
good guy in this situation
obviously the muzzle was aimed dead at
the kid's chest
no way to miss with the kid this close
just 10 feet away maybe
still cloaked in the shadow of the gas
station overhang kid i'm not going to
ask you again
i need you to put your hands on top of
your head and get on your knees
[ __ ] you [ __ ] like okay what
kind of [ __ ] kid is this
like is this some kind of iraq veteran
battle-hardened 10 year old who doesn't
give a [ __ ] like
what like i've never gotten a gun
pointed at me yet but
i can imagine it's pretty [ __ ]
terrifying and then if i'm a black
person in america and then a police
officer points a [ __ ] gun at me like
i would have trouble keeping my [ __ ]
together much less to insult and like
instigate the cop
and if all this happened to me as a
small child like i'll just [ __ ] myself
but uh we all know what these blacks are
like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] i'm serious
the kid's hand was nearly inside his
waistband now don't do that
oh sullivan said the kids smiled almost
gently don't the kid's smile broadened
the hand moved down into the pants get
the [ __ ] out of my hood
the kid cheerfully repeated i'll cap
your ass
kid i'm warning you o sullivan yelled
put your hands above your head
do it now the roar shattered the night
air a sonic boom in the blackness
the shot blew the kid off his feet
completely knocked him onto his back
o'sullivan reached for his radio
mechanically reported it
shots fired officer needs help at the
gas station on iowa and van dyke
oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh sullivan repeated as he moved
toward the body
the smoke rising from his glock he
pointed it down at the kid again
but the boy wasn't moving the blood
seeped through
homer simpson's face pulled around the
kid's lifeless body
the green had been replaced with a look
of instantaneous shock
his hand had fallen off his waistband
with the force of the shooting
in it was a toy gun the tip orange
plastic
really if only we could have established
that before shooting the kid
like man if only we had some kind of
armed
group that we pay who are like public
servants
and they go around keeping up the order
and they are specifically
trained to deal with these situations so
there is no bloodbath if only we had
those people but unfortunately we only
have this like [ __ ] street
executioner militia you know it uh
cape's a dark age in check but maybe we
could do better you know
and by the way at the beginning of the
book ben was complaining that the
taliban wants sharia law in afghanistan
but then if you're a kid who like messes
around with his pants and
you know [ __ ] talks a police officer
that in the west is apparently a death
sentence
so yeah dude hashtag bring sharia to
detroit
yeah this kid didn't have to die just
have some mujahideen haul the kid to a
sharia court and then i don't know
get him a whipping or something and
issue a fine to the parents i mean of
course there would be some scars on his
back but hey
in the decadent west he would [ __ ]
die thank you ben for showing us the way
forward but then the chapter continues
for a brief moment oh sullivan couldn't
breathe oh
man this is this is divine irony
the the gods do have a sense of humor
like seriously
when he looked up he saw them coming
dozens of them
the citizens of detroit coming out of
the darkness
congregating he could feel their eyes
and then when osullivan heroically
defended himself against a black kid and
executed him
these wild animals started climbing out
of the blasted ruins of what used to be
a nice white neighborhood
yeah so this is true allegiance by ben
shapiro everyone
later on he also shits on mexicans a
little bit like in ellen's chapter she's
working around the border
and then there's this huge migration
crisis there because prescott said that
children will not be deported and that
causes the cartel to start seeping
through the border like
why i don't know but those who did make
it swamped the available federal
resources
the border patrol spent their days
trying to help doctors screen for
disease
trying to dig up enough formula for
babies trying to patch up wounds and
find blankets
and keep the incipient gang members from
knifing each other
that meant the border had even less
personnel every day ellen heard
complaints from ranchers along the
border
they had been finding bodies on their
land or ripped panties from rape victims
or drugs yeah and then it goes on like
this
it's funny because the us is currently
breaking international law on the
southern border
the agreed upon procedure for migrants
and refugees is after crossing the state
border you show up to a police station
or a town hall or something
where you officially submit your asylum
application at which point you're
transferred to a reception center and
you wait until your asylum claim gets
judged basically and then you read your
granted or denied entry and those who
get denied get officially deported
now what the us currently does is they
catch people on the border before they
could make it to a place where they
could submit an official application
and then they hold them in inhumane
conditions and then they usually just
get deported back to mexico
by the way most of the illegal
immigrants in the us are from visa
overstays
from people who entered the country with
a visa but then just decided to stay
there
so ben's fear-mongering with this
immigration wave
doesn't really match up with reality
what a shock but then later on in the
book
texas governor bubba davis a big bear of
a man burly and fun-loving
just declares the war on mexico
essentially and sends in a bunch of
national guard into mexican territory
but hey i mean once again it's okay
because it's americans doing it you know
if a conservative governor invades
another country that's okay
if a conservative domestic terrorist
blows up a public building that's okay
if americans violate the border that's
okay
speaking of which at some point in the
book there is this who are they
the same people who shut down your form
the same people who attacked you
those people are americans it isn't
american to do those things
america means more than being born here
it means believing certain things
yeah so this is ben shapiro directly
telling us
stepping out from between the pages and
saying it to our faces
that people he disagrees with are not
real americans
you know liberals progressives leftists
people who don't want war in afghanistan
people who don't believe that america
has some exclusive global rights to
violate every international law
those people are not real americans and
this notion has a lot of
very funny implications such as if the
next attack on the capital is successful
and the far right does take over america
well they might just start getting rid
of these
un-american individuals and at that
point get ready
because after president for life donald
trump and his vp david duke will
institute the work freedom program for
liberals
and you and your family get shipped to
the liberal collection center
as you're ushered through the brick gate
you look to your right
and this is what you will see he's a
libertarian by the way
so this is true allegiance from ben
shapiro i would tell you the rest of the
book story but there isn't one
but the book itself provides an
incredibly enlightening and i would say
extremely disturbing
insight into ben shapiro's mind he is
okay with domestic terrorism if he
doesn't agree with the american
government
he thinks americans who disagree with
him are not really americans
he also thinks that black people are
just like out of control animals
he's okay with invading mexico he's also
okay with killing afghani civilians
he's also a gigantic war hawk but
there's one more thing about this book
that really irks me
i myself am an aspiring author so far
i've spent months
outlining world building practicing my
prose reading books about how to write
watching lectures about writing and
taking notes like the snippet i showed
you earlier about the maidan butler
dialogue
that was from brandon sanderson's
lectures on writing they're super useful
i've been learning about
characterization dialogue how to
properly deliver exposition
how to make the right promises how to
have satisfying payoffs i've been
working at my craft hard i've been
practicing
learning trying new things and so i
absolutely could write true allegiance
and i could do it much better to the
point where it would be
an average okay thriller that's kind of
entertaining
that's my current skill level but i
don't think that would be enough for me
to get published
for that i would still need to improve
my skills which i'm doing right now
but then along comes ben shapiro spews
out this literary diarrhea
and then it's immediately accepted and
published without ever checking for even
basic formatting problems
through this conservative publishing
house which is basically a safe space
for conservative authors because
in the meritocracy of the publishing
industry no one in their right mind
would even touch their work
anyway thank you for watching i'm i'm
all shapiroed out i think this book
actually gave me ptsd but the main thing
is that i made it
through and if you like my content
please don't forget to subscribe
and i'm going to see you at some point